-We're back with my friend
Andy Samberg.
My real-life friend,
it should be stressed.
Hopefully it's clear
to everybody
that we are good friends.
We talk a great deal,
and I've taken to --
giving you no warning,
I will FaceTime you
while we are filming our segment
we do on YouTube
called "Corrections,"
and I will just call you.
You don't know --
-Right.
-...you're gonna be on camera
when I answer the phone.
But about half of the time,
you answer.
-Yeah, I mean, there's been
a few times when you tried me
and I was in the bathroom and
I strongly considered answering.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But ultimately,
cooler heads prevailed.
[ Laughter ]
-You've always --
-I didn't say what I was doing
in the bathroom.
Maybe I was checking my phone
in the shower.
[ Laughter ]
-You hate being alone
in the bathroom,
it should be noted,
so I would ima--
I'm not surprised
you brought your phone.
-Well, thus "Wanna Come With,"
the most classic sketch
ever to be on your show.
-It was weird that you said
"Wanna Come With"
and that there wasn't just
an explosion of applause.
Do you want to explain
real quick
the sketch you wrote for "SNL"
called "Wanna Come With"?
-Yeah, it was based
on something I would do
while we worked at "SNL"
on the writing floor,
on writers' night.
It was a long walk
to the bathroom,
so I would ask people,
"Wanna come with?"
[ Laughter ]
So that I wasn't lonely
on the walk,
and subsequent, whatever I did
in there, you know?
-My favorite -- the time
it happened to me,
which is a story I love telling,
is you'd come into my office
at like 3:00 in the morning
and you'd say, "Hey, I'm going
to the bathroom,
wanna come with?"
and I would say,
"I don't wanna come with,"
and you would close the door.
And I had a frosted glass door,
so you could see the silhouette
of the person outside it.
And you'd be like, "Alright,"
and then you'd close the door
and you would just stay there.
[ Laughter ]
-And then you'd eventually go,
"I can see you."
and I'd go, "Wanna come with?!"
-[ Laughs ] "Wanna come with?!"
This was also -- talk about
hit characters you've done.
You came on our show,
and you've left this as a...
This was a story about --
There was a story, a true story
about mummies.
Some mummies were disturbed.
You came on the show as a mummy
who was upset they got disturbed
because in -- in the disturbing,
in the act of being disturbed --
-Yeah.
-...that happened.
Okay, well, I can see where
you're going with this,
and it's clickbait,
but fine, okay.
We can cut to a close.
I'll do it. I'll do it.
My doink fell off!
[ Laughter ]
That's what everyone wanted,
the catch phrase.
-Yeah. They want it.
You gave them the catch phrase.
We haven't -- I do --
Whenever you're on, I do want
to give you the opportunity
to maybe walk back some of the
crueler things you've said
about my dog Frisbee.
You know, I feel like as --
You know, again,
because you are a parent now,
I feel like you're a more
empathetic person.
You probably know
how hurtful it's been
that you said those things.
-Right, no.
But I will say...
[ Laughter ]
I do have a little
hot goss to share.
-Hot goss?
-Yeah, and it's...
you're not gonna like it.
But I do feel like your show
is a good place to spill it.
-Okay.
-The proverbial tea.
So, it's funny
you bring up Frisbee
because this past week,
Frisbee was actually spotted
canoodling with the mummy
whose doink fell off.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. It's pretty crazy.
They're Instagram official.
That's them sharing a milkshake,
I assume postcoital.
[ Laughter ]
Probably just banging
into each other.
I think there's some more.
Yeah, there's another one
there in the park.
They were having a picnic.
Probably just had sex
together,
probably just slamming
into each other.
There on the couch, postcoital.
Frisbee probably
just got reamed.
I mean maybe -- I guess
his doink fell back on?
This is probably
right after some oral.
[ Laughter ]
The doink probably fell back on.
Or they might be pegging, Seth.
I don't know.
They might be pegging.
It could be anything.
The point is, Frisbee is being
sexually satisfied finally,
no thanks to you.
And the thing
I got to say, Seth,
the thing I love the most
about it all
is if you look at your desk,
Stefon was right there.
He was right there,
and Frisbee chose correctly.
Frisbee chose the correct
choice, okay?
Further proving my point that
the mummy whose doink fell off
is a better and more enduring
character than Stefon.
I've always said that,
and you know that.
-I do know this --
I've never met anyone who,
the way you burned me
was playing out a scenario
where you had a lot of sex
with my dog.
[ Laughter ]
-Look.
I assume this is crushing.
And it's great television,
you know.
-Last time I saw you was
emotional to some degree.
It's always nice to see you,
but we were here
with the whole
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine" cast.
It was the night
the finale ended.
I certainly enjoyed having
you guys all here.
I hope you enjoyed it, as well.
-It was great.
It was so much fun.
And you know, it's been weird
not shooting the show anymore.
I've had a lot more free time.
-Uh-huh.
-I would say I spend most of my
time now working on development.
-Uh-huh.
That's a big L.A. thing.
-Developing a lot of projects.
-Yeah.
-I like to say I haven't
developed this much
since my sophomore year
of high school,
when my neck grew 3 feet
and the rest of my body
stayed the same size
and I looked like
David Spade's character
from "Emperor's New Groove"
turning into a llama.
[ Laughter ]
Everybody recommends that,
right?
[ Laughter ]
-An "Emperor's New Groove" ref!
-Yeah, I mean, it's -- this is
the time to talk about it.
-It is.
-But I will say,
I've been developing some stuff.
Not just, like, movies and TV
and stuff.
I developed a couple ideas
for your show.
-You did?
-Yeah.
And I thought maybe I could
try them out, if you don't mind.
-Of course.
-Okay, well, like, you know
how you do "A Closer Look"?
-I do.
-Yeah.
So, I was thinking that I could
do one and it would be --
You kind of do, like,
a deep dive in politics,
but I would do more of like
a macro view of it...
-Okay.
-...in a new segment
that I like to call
"A Further Look."
♪♪
Okay.
Okay, so,
people in politics are mad,
and everyone thinks
that they're right,
but the people on the other side
of the issue --
they think that they're right.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Further Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Really gonna resonate
with people, yeah.
-Yeah, did they play the package
on the end of it?
-They did, yeah.
-Okay, it's hard for me --
I can't hear.
I assume it's killing.
Okay, I have another one.
Okay, so...
-There's more?
-Yeah, you know how you do
"A Closer Look"?
-Y-Yes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, I'm gonna do
my own version...
[ Laughing ]
...in a segment that we call
"A Farther Look."
♪♪
Is the package happening?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
[ Laughing ]
Will you cue me when it's on?
Okay, let's take a --
let's take a look at this.
Oh, yeah.
See, there's Washington, D.C.
And that's a lot farther than
you're used to seeing it.
I think we've got
another one here.
That's like a satellite picture.
That's even farther.
That's, like, very far away.
This has been "A Farther Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are we clear?
-We're clear, yeah.
-Okay.
So, I do have one more.
[ Laughter ]
-I have one more. Okay.
-I know how I do
"A Closer Look."
Yeah, you know "A Closer Look."
That's the setup.
And a new segment I like to call
"A Farthing Look."
♪♪
Okay, so...
it's that.
That's a farthing.
And we're looking at it.
That's from 1945,
so that's a good one.
This has been "A Farthing Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's Andy Samberg, everybody.
"Baking It" --
"Baking It" is available to
stream on Peacock, December 2nd.